hallo leute habt ihr unser video gesehen
in dem wir euch nützliche setzte
vorgestellt haben die ihren telefonaten
nutzen könnt heute und auch in zukunft
möchten wir euch weitere telefon
situationen vorstellen damit er für
jedes telefonat auf deutsch gewandert
seid los geht's heute geht es um das
thema essen über das telefon bestellen
sie wird gleich in zwei verschiedenen
restaurants an ofen
zunächst ruft er sie bei einem
restaurant in ihrer nachbarschaft an um
essen zu bestellen
sie wird essen für eine größere gruppe
von freunden bestellen
die alle andere essgewohnheiten und
intoleranzen haben
tante klarinette hier du sprichst mit
lisa wie kann ich dir helfen hallo hier
ist isabelle schmidt
ich möchte gerne essen bei euch
bestellen hier ein kleiner hinweis bei
vielen restaurants insbesondere junge
und neue restaurants nutzen die
mitarbeiter ihre gäste im restaurant und
auch am telefon wenn ihr direkt geduzt
werdet könnt ihr euren gesprächspartner
auch nutzen sollten sie allerdings
gesetzt werden würde ich euch empfehlen
den gesprächspartner am telefon auch zu
sitzen
wir haben auch letztens eine episode zum
thema duzen und siezen aufgenommen
schaut mal hier klar schieß los was
können wir bringen
was können wir dir bringen was möchtest
du bestellen
also wir hätten gerne einmal die
vegetarische kürbis lasagne
dazu hätte ich eine frage sind in dieser
zwiebeln dazu habe ich eine frage ja in
der lasagne sinn zwiebeln soll mit die
rauslassen ja bitte ich habe an einer gi
und ich vertrage keine zwiebeln
ich habe eine allergie ich vertrage
etwas nicht klar
dann bereiten die quiz lösen hier ohne
zwiebeln vor was kann ich noch tun was
kann ich noch für euch tun
super danke dann hätten wir gerne noch
zwei mal pommes einmal mit wasabi
mayonnaise und einmal rot weiß
wir hätten gerne zwei pommes die
normalen fans freut's die süßkartoffel
pommes oder die etwas breiteren
bayerischen trennen die normalen
franchise bitte und dann hab ich noch
frage eine von uns hat eine gluten und
laktose intoleranz habt ihr gerichte für
sie eine person hat eine gluten und eine
laktoseintoleranz
ja klar wir haben für jeden etwas schaut
doch mal in ruhe in unsere speisekarte
wir haben dort alle allergene
aufgenommen und die vegetarischen
gerichte sind auch markiert die
vegetarischen und veganen gerichte sind
markiert wir haben alle aller gene in
die speisekarte aufgenommen
dann könnt ihr ganz in ruhe aussuchen
und online stellen
ihr könnt online bestellen das ist super
da machen wir das vielen dank wusstet
ihr schon dass wir seit einiger zeit
auch workshops für die super easy german
episoden erstellen
diese enthalten immer drei übungen für
beginner wenn ihr jetzt an easy german
paging mitgeht werdet könnt ihr das mal
ausprobieren und übungen zu dieser folge
machen
nun ruft die sie bei einem anderen
restaurant an
sie hat schon vor zwei stunden essen
bestellt doch dieses wurde noch nicht
geliefert
kaffee blaumeise martina martin sind wie
kann ich ihnen helfen
guten tag hier ist isabelle schmidt ich
möchte mich erkundigen was wird meiner
bestellung passiert ist ich habe bereits
vor 2 stunden bei ihnen essen bestellt
was ist mit meiner bestellung passiert
ich habe bei ihnen essen bestellt
das tut mir leid können sie mir ihre
adresse nennen können sie mir ihre
adresse nennen
ja das ist die waldstraße 21 schmidt
wallstraße 120 das war zweimal das
vegetarische tagesgericht ja genau ich
schaue mal eben sehr liefer boot hat
gemerkt dass er bein war aber keine
ausgemacht hat es hat keiner auf gemacht
das stimmt aber nicht ich war die ganze
zeit zu hause
ich war doch die ganze zeit zu hause das
ist komisch ist ihre kinder kaputt
nein meine kinder es nicht kaputt
bewohnen im hinterhof aber das habe ich
im kommentarfeld vermerkt das habe ich
aber im kommentarfeld vermerk okay es
scheint zu einem missverständnis
gekommen zu sein
wir schicken den liefer boten gleich
noch mal los es scheint ein
missverständnis zu geben
wir schicken den nie verboten noch mal
los für ihre nächste bestellung bei uns
schenken wir ihnen fünf euro als
wiedergutmachung für die wartezeit für
ihre nächste bestellung bei uns schenken
wir ihnen fünf euro ok vielen dank da
sind sie endlich sie haben aber eben
nicht geklingelt
wir haben wirklich lange gewartet
danke für die lieferung danke für die
lieferung
das essen ist ja mittlerweile kalt das
essen ist kalt naja ist jetzt auch egal
schönen tag noch es ist jetzt egal so
das waren zwei weitere situationen mit
neuen vokabeln für telefongespräche
ich hoffe diese helfen euch weiter wenn
ihr demnächst essen nach hause bestellt
und schaut mal bei paypal vorbei wenn
ihr mitglied werden könnte übungen zu
dieser episode und allen anderen easy
german episoden machen hab noch einen
schönen tag und bis bald da sind sie ja
ähnlich
[Musik]